[Music]
hello and welcome to dead stream my name
is Susie and I will be your host this
episode I am joined this afternoon by
the fluff of nightmares lady what it
rabbit hey guys we're also joined
tonight by the third voice of death
mortis media hello everyone
tonight's guest lives in the world of
the strange you know him as mr. Davis
hello hello let us know in the chat if
you guys can see the stream because
YouTube's telling me that there's nobody
watching it which I don't think is true
that audio is getting through to you
guys you're listening to episode 7 of
the dead stream in this episode we'll
talk about Marble Hornets and debate the
the debate of monetizing death and the
fight between two big names and horror
we'll also be taking your questions from
the chat later in the broadcast and
super chats will definitely be addressed
so send them over and last episode we
also had an issue a technical issue
where it was sending my audio in before
everybody else's so it sounded like I
was interrupting them but I wasn't if
you guys experienced any issues like
that also let us know in the chat but
let's get on to our first topic Marble
Hornets released a teaser for something
new that they're coming out with in 2018
what do you guys think about that I
think it's exciting ok I think I think
Marble Hornets was one of the first I
guess you could call an Arg kind of deal
and I don't remember how it ended
because I didn't finish it dude does
anyone know how it ended I do I won't
spoil it for everybody
good point good point but it was kind of
an open ending I'll say okay I think
it's really cool that they're opening
back up because the last subs upload was
what three years ago has it been three
years already I think so last time I
looked at their channel yeah
so this character that they have I've
got it up on the strain for those of you
who are watching it live this is the
mask of Scully which is not to be
confused with masky who's like one of
the main characters so Scully was in I
think just one entry and basically the
main character finds this tape and it
shows this skull mask and he and then it
shows like some footage of Jay the like
the made about human bad guy type of
thing and his girlfriend being stalked
by Slenderman and it never it never ties
up like what the skull mask is and then
later on we meet the the mask II mask so
it's interesting that they have left
that open and now we're possibly gonna
come back to it do you guys think that
it'll be a continuation of Marble
Hornets or like a new series I don't
know it I mean you said it hinted
open-ended right so it might be a
continuation it's hard to explain
because yeah it was there are multiple
ways you could interpret the ending I
guess but it was kind of a conclusive
ending right so that'll be interesting
to see what they do with Marble Hornets
going forward in 2018 yeah so have you
guys all seen the new Slender Man
trailer yeah I did yeah I like the tone
of voice I just it's it's something I
think would have worked a lot better
when slender was at its peak I think
it's a little late in the game to be
putting out a random Slender Man movie
that's just my opinion on it
yeah I mean I kind of feel the same way
but at the same time I don't know if any
of you watched channel 0 on sci-fi like
the first season was based off the first
season based on candle Cove and the
second season was based on knowin house
so bringing creepypasta to the small
screen I think worked out really well at
least with the second season so it might
work on the big screen but with such
I mean it's kind of not a really
relevant carry yeah yeah but kind of
like we're gonna try to get some money
off of this thing they used to be really
big and maybe bring it back it got like
a second win when all the games came out
even but it's not even relevant to that
anymore
the cool thing about Marble Hornets it
was such a slow build and it was really
just unraveling this mystery and you
never knew when something scary was
gonna happen because it was so spread
out over like what did we say at least
five hours I think yeah but if you're
putting it into a movie and you can just
tell from the trailer it looks like
there's gonna be a lot of jump scares it
doesn't seem to capture like the same
magic yeah that's definitely not what
slinger should be about his jump scary
stuff I did a video on the trailer which
came out this morning but briefly one of
the things that I said it was that it
seems to be based more off of the like
the real-life public perception of
Slender Man like the Slender Man story
that happened in 2014 and like the
Slender Man fandom as opposed to the
lore of Slender Man which she's gonna
remake it out with Jeff the killer
because we'll get back to that and the
whole baptism on fire video a little bit
later in the stream but like how do you
guys feel about them taking the more
realistic approach I think it it could
be done well I think but I just don't
know why they chose Slender Man yeah but
I guess you know and you think
creepypasta that's the first thing that
comes to mind other than like everyone
like laughing jack or anything like that
but who do you think if they wouldn't
have picked Slender Man would have been
a much better candidate for a horror
film at this point in time do you think
then financially or to make a good film
makes a good film that's a good question
like his particular character that's
like super relevant at this very moment
yeah he's kind of like the the mascot
for creepypastas kind of genre mm-hmm
it's kind of gone away from the original
characters in recent years
oh yeah for sure with the rise of like
the true scary stories and mr. nightmare
and stuff who will also talk about later
in the stream so stick around some I
said some I said I was I was hack I was
Jack I don't think I was Jack would make
a good movie because his story is so
short and there's really nothing to it
mmm like it's just something that people
can cosplay as and make fan art open all
that good just a killer
same thing yeah I think Jeff the killer
would be like the answer for the most
financially successful movie and I think
I think they could actually make a
decent movie out of that story and you
know there's a lesser-known I don't know
if you want to call it a creepypasta or
a true scary story but there's a story
called my best friend tried to ruin my
life oh that's a good one oh man that is
such a good story I've always thought
that was amazing as a movie that would
be there like there would be an
incredible movie or maybe even just a
short film you know that's such a great
story if you guys aren't familiar with
it be Busta has a really good narration
oh yeah oh yeah but as far as like why
they chose Slenderman
whenever I I'm at like family parties or
something and my older relatives are
asking me what I do and I try to explain
it like explain what creepypasta is
usually the only one that they'll ever
recognize is Slenderman yeah yeah
because it didn't it didn't start as a
creepypasta it was just a photo entered
into a contest and then stories came
from that photo so it's not necessarily
a creepypasta even at its roots some
more people heard about it I think yeah
yeah and then what's the whole thing
with the eyes in this new trailer like
it seems like they're just trying to
make it this generic you know teen
thriller mixed with like disease movie
choice like maybe I'm missing something
but I've never known
I like other than the fact that
Slenderman doesn't have a face to be
part of of like what Slenderman is no I
haven't heard that either they're just
trying to like nah I think they're just
trying to integrate their own ideas into
it and it's kind of in my opinion
modeling what I what they're trying to
do
yeah like entering a bunch of generic
stuff is just gonna make a generic
horror movie don't do I mean I want to
have hopes for it but I can't yeah I
really want to like it yeah I'll watch
it and give it a chance
I'll give it a fair chance but yeah
right Lisa I probably would have been
way more excited about it had it been
relevant at the time yeah only four
years yeah yeah I think the reason that
happened the reason Sol aids because
wasn't there like some copyright issues
with the word creepypasta for a while
because I think like Warner Brothers
wanted to make it creepypasta movie but
they couldn't get the copyright for the
name it seems like a strange reason to
stop making a movie just because of a
name they just change what it's called
or don't say it I suppose I think then
the word creepypasta got trademarked and
they were trying to buy the trailer so
they can make the movies yeah that's
hilarious because I mean that because
they are like modern urban legends that
they're technically in the public domain
yeah yes it specifically copyrighted
which is a different story but that's
interesting yeah because the other thing
that came to mind was for them to do
like a Twilight Zone kind of compilation
movie with a bunch of short stories of
creepypasta is brought to film yeah yeah
maybe it would work better as like a
Netflix original series yeah not a full
movie like give an hour to each each
character to you know like I'm roll with
it and you can that'd be quite good and
then everyone gets their own segment and
their own decent story properly done
instead of a net full on movie that's
kind of what Channel Zero is like each
season is a different story like the
first ones candle Cove which was yeah
and I think that's our idea
that was not great oh that's so
unfortunate because it's such an
interesting story yeah but like I mean
they didn't really have a whole lot to
go off of
yeah it's true it wasn't bad but it
wasn't great either the second season
was a thousand times better
I can see candle Cove being good and I
haven't seen channel zero yeah everybody
tells me to watch it but I haven't seen
it I could see it being good if they
didn't take the exact story from the
candle Cove curry pasta but rather they
took the concept and like a bunch of
different characters that were involved
with it and that's actually yeah that's
actually exactly what they did they
followed up with the people who were in
the original story they're now adults
and candle Cove has kind of made a
comeback and now their kids have seen it
and you know I don't get too much into
it but if you're gonna watch it I would
just go ahead and skip to the second
season I'm a little biased cuz highly
absolutely love knowing house yeah with
that one it's like the knowin house is
sort of just like this haunted house
that shows up out of nowhere and it has
people know what it is so they're like
oh we're gonna go in and if you've read
the story you kind of get an idea of
what is going to happen but nothing that
happened the story happens in the show
which is good I think that way it wasn't
predictable really I'm reading the
comments here someone's talking about
lady white rabbits narration of braska
that would be another one that would
make a good movie I think oh yeah I was
just thinking that like that would be an
amazing movie as well yeah Roscoe was
good it's so crazy like it's like these
little Internet stories and some of them
just absolutely blow everything out of
the water yeah yeah that's what I like
about it is like anybody can write these
stories and and make something for
people to enjoy they don't have to be
famous or anything you could just be a
person yeah I mean what was it pen pal
got turned into a full-length novel I
think yeah sure did yeah it's crazy it's
really cool
so our next story is gonna be about the
channels that are reloading content from
horror channels and taking that as their
own so the big one that happened
recently is someone made a channel
called well I mean I'll just say that
they named the channel after one of the
big narrators so okay like what do you
guys make of all this
why are people doing this I think it's
coming yes quick money and they're doing
it not just of the horror genre but like
gaming genres as well so easy to just
take somebody's video and reupload it
with no thought process or content of
your own and make some quick money off
of it yeah yeah but really stupid yeah I
think we're getting into this later but
in the whole new monetization policy
that YouTube just rolled out I think
it's gonna help stop that kind of thing
because yeah you can't immediately
monetize your content anymore which is
good yeah I mean I was one of these I
was gonna ask yeah and these channels
you know they upload like probably five
or six videos at a time just so you know
they can optimize search engine and all
that good stuff but I hope it's gonna
stop soon with the new monetization
policy but I guess we'll see yeah
hopefully that does improve the
situation I just don't understand like
the entire logic behind it just seems
like there are things that don't add up
so yeah like they they'll use a popular
narrators name and avatar but then
they'll be floating videos from like a
bunch of different people and they're
too lazy to change the branding on it so
yeah you'll see like reuploads from
Southern cannibal and mr. nightmare and
mortis media but it's under like a
different name so it's clearly like a
compilation so if you're if you're a fan
of the popular narrator and you go to
find this channel and you find it on
accident then you'll immediately find
out that this is a person so I don't
know who our who's falling for this
yeah well clearly some people because
they do they do get some news every
night
I personally someone sent me a link and
they were like Oh someone's someone's
re-uploading with your content you know
some of the videos had like a good
hundred hundred and fifty views and they
gained about 70 subs on site wow this is
really weird obviously it wasn't just
mine it was stolen from a handful of
people but me I don't know maybe they
think if I upload all these videos then
I'll instantly get 150 subs maybe delete
them all before anyone notices then
upload my own content and have like a
small little mini boost maybe I'm not
really sure that could there are some
reasons it sort it sort of makes sense
doesn't it but yeah that does make sense
but then but then of course they get
this notification in their newsfeed this
person you didn't sub to has now
uploaded something about well I don't
know what that is so it seems like they
typically have high subs but low views
yeah you would think it would be the
opposite and I think that's because they
upload so much at one time thank you
yeah they they get a huge backlog and
they're like I'm gonna put forty seven
and a half videos up at one time and
just rake in the views doesn't work like
that yeah I'm a little offended because
I've never had my content noticed yeah
here we go yeah the gucci mane reap some
brits me off yes album after me i found
out about that today actually when i was
trying to find like your picture and
stuff to put in the stream yeah it's
kind of funny like I sound pretentious I
found it because I was youtubing my own
name first the first search result was
good to me I'm like what okay that works
I guess and it seems like these channels
get to several hundred subscribers
before getting caught so again it's like
who are these subscribers cuz if they're
people who are interested in horror
content they probably know a thing or
two about the community and there's
lutely too to get caught really early on
maybe there botting maybe so our next
topic is the controversial baptism on
fire video so basically what happened
there is baptism on fire did he's a
horror creator here on YouTube and he
does a lot of silly stuff as well so he
was doing a video where he was reading
and making fun of some of these Wattpad
horror fan fictions like these romances
between Slender Man and Jeff the killer
and that type of thing and he filmed me
intro of the video in the graveyard and
a lot of people said like oh he
shouldn't be doing this this is wrong
he's trying to monetize death so what do
you guys think about that whole
situation I think it's fine yeah I think
it's it's pretty stupid to get upset
about it it's just the intro it's not
like he's making the whole movie whole
video about being in a graveyard I guess
and who cares even and he's making money
off of it it's still his work so even if
you didn't make the whole video like a
whole short film that takes place in a
graveyard I don't know it's just a
location install he was doing anything
offensive digging up the bodies and
peeing in the columns I might get some
people upset I don't know I don't know I
don't know I'm really sick of I don't
know about you guys but it's just like
these sensitive people who are just
ruining good things by being offended
yeah yeah the video has a very positive
like to dislike ratio
it's like 7031 dislike so I mean yeah
yeah it seems like that's typically what
happened is like the small majority of
people were offended ended up sounding
much louder because just the whole
controversy starts around it yeah it's
kind of interesting it's like it's like
a loud minority even though that's kind
of a oxymoron but oh yeah and the
upsetting thing is his video is really
good it's really funny oh yeah he makes
it very long
mm-hm and then like he's in the chat he
says ah thanks the video had no cemetery
slash death related metadata in the
title or thumbnail and there was no
profit slash views made off the death
yeah
baptism if you wanna if you want to come
on and say something about it then hit
me in the DMS but yeah it's like who are
the who are the victims of this you know
they don't care it's just people getting
offended yeah because they can so what
do you guys think about just the concept
of monetizing death as a whole I think
it depends how you tackle it really
because death is yeah obviously
incredibly sensitive to a lot of people
yeah I mean there are some creators who
obviously a very well-known now and have
monetized death in the wrong way is
something that they should have never
done you know you shouldn't go to a
place in the hopes that you find someone
dead to them glorify and and monetize it
yeah I think that's very clearly wrong
but you know if you go to a graveyard
and you know it's a public place anyone
can turn up to a graveyard if you're
filming there and you're not and you're
not saying and you know you're not
making a mockery you're not
disrespecting anyone then what's the
problem exactly it's just another place
you can be filming in the street and no
one's gonna have a problem with it
because there might be a little behind
you I think what you described is like
distasteful but not necessarily wrong
and I also want to bring up that baptism
in the chat said all of the graves are
at least a century old yeah and I think
the reason that he brings that up is
it's not like people are they're trying
to mourn and you're they're making a
ruckus like yeah everybody who ever knew
any of these people is already gone a
graveyard basically for display like if
you're not going there to film who is
going there it's a waste of space no I
mean yeah you gotta draw the line
somewhere you know obviously what what
logan paul did was absolutely atrocious
but i I don't think baptism is in the
wrong here no absolutely not
it seems like when it's youtubers then
they always make a big deal out of it
yeah I don't know to me like death is as
natural as waking up in the morning and
it just seems like the traditional media
is trying to make youtubers look bad
yeah there's so many things that are
monetized by the traditional media like
the mainstream traditional news litter
every day they just report on people's
deaths and there's ads running every
five minutes can refuting every five
minutes disaster movies they're like
some of the the most some insane stream
is offline uh no it's telling me stream
complete yeah it's it's given me a
loading circle YouTube is not receiving
enough video if we never had this happen
oh about those technical difficulties we
were just gonna get to that I blame you
I blame the Jeep I in the FCC
Jeep I god I don't like that guy can you
guys hear us at all on the chat like
type 1 if you can it's still it's still
up for me it says it's live ok thanks
good says it's fine
shout cheaper yeah it's still telling me
video output Wow I can hear it I guess
so what was I saying disaster movies
like those are the most mobile movies
out there yeah and I mean if if you're
gonna get mad at somebody for filming in
a graveyard that is centuries old and
you might as well get mad at the news
for talking about murders and things of
that nature
you know I mean the entire time the Las
Vegas shooting was being covered they
were running like ads the entire time
coke ads like hi Tyler
ads but nobody ever says anything about
that yeah and I think we already
discussed this but the whole thing with
the late-night Jimmy's being able to
talk about it and monetize and
everything and then once youtubers are
do it doing it then they just get
destroyed
yeah and then the one other thing I
thought about
is Facebook so Facebook recently has
been pushing their creator platform it's
not very good but we'll see where it
goes really and they won't allow you to
upload anything that has to deal with
tragedy or death funny thing is Facebook
has a feature built-in for when you die
for your pub for your profile to become
public and what are people to go to it
and like leave there to see your program
after you're dead so they're collected
well they're collecting data from these
people and they're selling that data and
making a profit off of it wow that is
Wow which I have no problem with them
doing that I think death is just a
natural thing and it shouldn't do it
shouldn't be treated any differently
than any other thing that we might do
but it I just don't like them having the
double standard and making a big deal
out of it when it's youtubers yeah yeah
yeah I think the media really does have
it in for a lot of youtubers just
because I think they're just not happy
that people can make their own way on
this platform or they see success and
they just get jealous what I'm making a
really interesting article of earlier
you know when PewDiePie had his first
scandal with the Nazi thing and you know
it really really really resonated it's
just like oh you know like if you know
they just make a really big ruckus about
and you know he lost everything and
everyone who behind that one must have
been laughing like yeah and you know we
we brought down the great PewDiePie he's
not anything yeah yeah you know I'm
thought and for what and for what you
know like he did something wrong and
then just everyone gives him gives him
slap about it but you know if it been
someone someone else like like a I don't
know like like a sports player or
something what would they have done yeah
they wouldn't have been kicked off their
team nothing would have happened it's
just cuz they know the media that they
have power in certain places that they
use it to bring people who you know some
people down that's not very nice
yeah and just to be clear for everybody
who's not familiar with the PewDiePie
situation he literally did nothing wrong
he
was making jokes he was making jokes and
saying oh they're gonna take this out of
context and that's exactly what they did
they took his words out of context and
spliced him up to make it look like he
was saying exactly you think at one clip
they actually used where he was just
pointing off-camera and they used it as
a way to be like oh look he's doing the
hit yeah yeah and I'm like oh my god
come on man that's just so sad now I'll
defend him on that because it was jokes
it was bad jokes you know they were kind
of not the greatest joke she could make
they were edgy and all that but the
whole live stream incident like him
making edgy jokes I have no problem with
and like there are plenty there plenty
of like South Park they make edgy jokes
they don't get any back up something
wrong with it I don't think anyway so
any last thoughts on that story before
we move on no I think we're good all
right so we're gonna take some questions
very shortly here so if you all just
want to start flooding the chat with
your questions but while you do that
we're gonna talk about the milestones
our very own mortis media in 50k
congratulations man thank you
more I've gotta say like it's really
impressive what you're doing with your
channel right now I don't think there's
anybody else in the community or on
YouTube who's doing video uploads every
day and they're all an hour and there
are quality stories I think thank you
honestly it's you know it's it's very
very very tiring you even sleep like
don't understand it is quite challenging
and I'm trying to figure out a decent
work-life balance but there's you know
like 8 9 10 hours every day even
weekends isn't healthy so they're gonna
be gonna be you know like changing
things up
- maybe you know not pump out as much or
just change things change things up
because it's just unfeasible I mean I
don't know if you guys know of uh now I
can't even remember I hate everything he
tweeted out a few oh yeah a week or so
ago like how the people who pump our
baby content how how do you live with
yourselves and I was thinking yeah yeah
that's what I'm doing
yeah it's challenging very challenging
man
so mr. Davis you upload what is it twice
a week or once a week three three times
a week three times Monday Wednesday and
Friday yeah and mr. Davis is very much
known in the community for being ahead
of schedule and how so what's your
experience with that more do you ever
get ahead of schedule do you ever have
like a backlog of videos I wish I mean
today is a divine miracle I've got
today's video up and tomorrow's is all
it needs to be is uploaded and and I'm
good but and I'm taking so much deserved
time off this weekend just you know
other than the stream no work at all
none and then back to Monday it's gonna
be back to pumping out you know that
that content and trying to figure out my
schedule which is what I've been doing
for the last month I'm sort of getting
there but it takes time to to get it but
I really I really respect you mr. Davis
it takes so much planning and so much
dedication to be able to you know
schedule out and do all that and I know
you've been doing it for a long time and
I've always thought my goodness he he is
he's a wizard I could never do that but
so you know kudos big respect you man
thanks man
Carrie saying get I had everything on
the dirt on the dead stream dude I would
fun II he has done podcast before yeah
let's get the drawer maybe a podcast so
much more maybe when you see him at the
YouTube space over in London yeah hey
listen listen I hate you do podcast come
come join us at 10:00 on you know on one
Saturday or Sunday it'd be good yeah
yeah definitely him up
or these irrelevant people who are you
he did a collaboration with that creepy
rating right that creepy reading yeah
yeah that's it
I'm gonna be honest I when I watch the
video it seemed a little forced from I
have everything's part a little bit
because I don't think he was like
familiar with the concept but it was
still a good love good love it was good
I have to check that one out yeah so are
other milestones were chills hitting
million can that for a couple years and
he has a really good channel yeah
congratulations to Dylan and mr.
nightmare number one in the community is
now at 3 million that's so insane
the funny thing about it was he hit two
million exactly one year before he hit
two million on Christmas in 2016 and hit
three million on Christmas in 2017 wow
that's insane dude kissy how often does
the upload now like week every other
week yeah yeah I mean it really doesn't
seem like anything is going to dethrone
him anytime soon because that much but
when he does upload they're very
successful and then whenever you look up
a certain topic he's always his video is
always in the search like if you search
a movie theater on YouTube right now the
top thing is mr. nightmares videos
because he has accumulated so much watch
time of her over the span of his career
and it's amazing because his watch times
his videos on even that long and yet
he's still killing it yeah like 1213
minutes and you're like wow so many
people for just these short little
little tiny nuggets of horror uh
and he was able to overcome a
controversy like a year year and a half
ago as well and he's been going strong
so I think he handled that well yeah to
be honest
I mean something like that something is
serious is straight up you know
copyright kind of thing can ruin
somebody's career if you're not careful
but I think he did it he covered it well
and he's always very good about
crediting the authors in his videos now
yeah yeah I don't have to worry about
that anymore yeah yeah unless it's a no
sleep story then obviously I credit the
author but I'm on good terms with a
bunch of no sleep authors you know so
and you read a lot as well yeah hmm I
will have to we'll have to do a writing
Club at some point oh yeah
so we've got a few questions being
scared asked what everybody is a perfect
slice of pizza no shame Hawaiian yeah
take a pineapple and cut it up and put
on the pizza
I want that pizza to be hidden under all
the pineapples
[Laughter]
so Eddie that's not a bad slice of pizza
because mine Apple maybe a couple
jalapenos on there good Ramsay doesn't
control me I tell you what really makes
a good slice of pizza well I mean more
since you said Hawaiian pizza you're
probably gonna lose like seven eight
thousand subscribers but I think my
answer might actually be even more
controversial than that I'm probably
gonna lose like fifteen sixteen thousand
subscribers when I say this but I don't
I think what happened was like if you
ever eat something and then you get sick
afterwards and your brain kind of
associates it yeah I think that happened
to me with pizza so I'm not able to eat
cheese oh I thought and I I love pizza
like the whole
questions like what would you eat if you
could only one more thing for the rest
of your life and my answer is always
pizza I love you pudding that yeah you
keep that to yourself for me it's either
pizza or cereal
I love cereal yeah even though I'm
lactose intolerant
I'll take it I'll take the risk so our
next question is would you if given the
chance to participate in a horror
aarg and for this week I don't know he's
talking about alternate reality game
yeah yeah yeah that's pretty sweet yeah
I mean I can't think of any situation
where I wouldn't want to do that one
that we can participate in what's going
on I'm only doing voice acting no no I'm
not leaving my house I'm not going
anywhere you want to be in my er G just
come to like Utah no I think it would be
cool though to be involved in something
like that yeah speaking of AR G's can we
quickly touch on what was up with
brainbots Twitter account the other day
is it still like that
no she fixed it she changed her Twitter
handle to [ __ ] but but normal now but
for a while there she was tweeting out
some really weird stuff yeah she was
like this is my cat and it was a picture
of a shoe I mean it was so cryptic and
she changed her Twitter handle to wrong
as well I don't know what it was I was
actually kind of thinking because I
don't know how long ago it was but a
while ago she was saying that she wants
to do like some big project and she
wanted suggestions for topics to
investigate yeah it has to be big so I
wonder if she's doing like a social
experiment type of thing where she's
like pretending to be actor lost her
mind or so maybe so
weird but yeah she had her her profile
picture was just like a photo of the
wall right yeah really weird it's like I
want to say she was trying to start
she's got some had a secret project
going on but at the same time I think
that's one of the things that she told
people who are creating a orgies not to
do yeah so maybe she could also just be
making fun of it yeah she could be
taking the piss out of it but I don't
know it's it's weird just to give you
guys a good idea she's got a string of
about five tweets here now kitty is
playing with his awesome toys sounds
like we have a guest be on your best
behavior mr. kitty
this is not a game mystery games are
supposed to be fun and interactive no
mr. kitty you're wrong and that's it
well I get the door yeah it was it was
interesting oh yeah makes poke 100k
that's pretty sweet oh yeah yeah how did
we not talk about that his his success
is just absolutely incredible but didn't
we talk about it lasts like we do that
the last episode that we said he was at
50k still two months 50k
yeah that's insane gosh yeah I mean it
feels like everybody's hitting 100k
right now yeah no at least you're
halfway there man I mean I can just tell
like Envia in the next stream it's gonna
be like ninety-nine point whatever three
subs who all unsub because you didn't
eat pizza right yeah any other questions
you guys noticed in the chat someone
asked what dead horror writer would you
have as a guest ooh
think about that somebody else go first
I could be Super Bass they can just say
like Edgar Allan Poe yeah
I think you'd be an interesting
interesting dude talk to you cuz like
let's assume he knows he's dead right
yeah what's the suit met so cuz there's
so much mystery around his death he like
died on a park bench talking to himself
or something yeah I'll be like yo how
what happened what's wrong with you yeah
I think that'd be cool but did you see
that moving the raven senior in high
school at the time and i was super
excited for it then it just it was bad i
don't know if this is if my answer is
gonna be cheating but it's someone who
is a writer and has written horror but
is more known for someone else and i
would say
alfred hitchcock oh yeah pretty cool i
think he still fits into that you know
that horror thing but you know he is
mostly known for like suspense and yeah
well he's also mostly known for a lot of
adaptations and stuff yeah yeah i think
it would work I'm gonna his I am to be
like most of the stuff that he most of
the movies that he's written are not his
more notable ones like he got notorious
in there murder yeah blackmail there's a
few of them yeah somebody said Poe died
and someone else's clothes sassy that's
just so weird
any other ideas on that one
I'm yeah it's not horror probably more
sci-fi but Rob Stirling hmm cuz I love
The Twilight Zone and he wrote he wrote
a Twilight Zone book that was incredible
okay okay
Mart well there was this one but I can't
remember his name he was an Irish writer
he wrote pretty good ghost stories sort
of semi believable ones as well
I honestly can't remember
but his book saying on my shelf which
isn't anywhere near me otherwise er
cheekily gone and had a look but I
honestly Carmen was named but he's Irish
and he's at least 100 years dead so
there you go guys are we monetizing
death right now
oh dear I'm another question that came
to mind is if you wanted to like if you
knew that you were going to die and you
wanted to imprint your legacy how would
you do it see people talk about like
monetizing death is being disrespectful
but what if someone like there was a
creator on YouTube who died and then
they took away their partner status yeah
well I don't know it depends I if they
took it away from no reason to be a bit
insulting isn't it it's like well their
lives are still there you know the
videos the proceeds can still go to
their family it's not like when a writer
dies the books like oh well shame now
the books for free yeah yeah that
doesn't happen for another 71 years or
whatever it is public domain I think a
cool thing to do would be like if I
don't know if writing it in your will
that's it seems a little extreme but
like if you were to pass away while you
were still working on YouTube videos you
could say something like all the ad
revenue from this point forward goes to
a charity of your choice or something
like that yeah that could be cool but I
don't see them taking away partner
status from somebody because they died
because they died for just because like
they changed their requirements oh yeah
yeah
another question do you know the way I
do know the way oh man I got so many
questions this time I will take a couple
more any plans on having
rain bat as a guest yes she was almost
our 30s but she was on hiatus at the
time she Holi and now she's
malfunctioning right so assuming that
she's still mentally all there after her
life Twitter tirade then yes she will be
a guest in the future let's take one
more favorite type of horror that's a
good question I'll say I hate jump-scare
kind of are I'm more of a suspenseful
like slow burn kind of are I don't hate
jump scares I live there anyway yeah I
hate when they rely entirely on jump
scares like Slenderman trailer for
example but I think I think Jeff's kids
are awesome when they're built up to and
based out properly yeah yeah for sure my
favorite type of horror is psychological
horror yeah I was just gonna say that
yeah yeah
I think a lot of my favorite horror
movies a lot of people would consider to
be just dark psychological thrillers but
like having the sense of mystery just
adds another layer for me and making me
think about it and getting into my head
yeah that stuff's really interesting to
me yeah that's true of a videogames for
me too
I've been really obsessed with doki-doki
lurcher club lately and it's just
because throughout half of that game I'm
just like what the [ __ ] is happening and
that's feeling can you explain inside
the audience uh it is a free game on
Steam yeah you can get it right now it's
not right for the stream yeah it's um
it's a hidden horror game that's kind of
masquerading as a Japanese dating sim
and yeah it's really really when [ __ ]
starts hitting the fan it gets really
good
so any other any other favorite types of
four before we move on all right so we
have got the the John Carpenter story
Rotten Tomatoes sent out a tweet that
said John Carpenter would have been 75
today happy birthday
good job obviously John Carpenter is
still alive and he he made sure that
everybody on Twitter so my question to
you guys is was this an honest mistake
or some kind of PR stunt for Rotten
Tomatoes maybe cuz I'm looking at it now
his birthday is the 16th of January so
they were late and he's not even 75 he's
70 ya know I think they'd actually did
tweet 70 I just read it off I mean I
don't know it could have been a mistake
I guess I don't know that's a little
weird yeah here's the tweet right hey
I'm John Carpenter would have been 70
years old today we celebrate his
birthday by looking back at his what
could it just do not miss communication
within the person who did that yeah I
mean you never know maybe you never know
who is running the the social media
accounts for these websites yeah yeah it
could be just someone who couldn't be
bothered to check but to me this just
feels like if he are stunt his seventies
not even yeah I mean that's not super
old and if I saw that somebody was 70 I
would assume that they were alive yeah
yeah but you know they think if they'd
have noticed they were wrong if they've
got a backlash they live deleted it
immediately and rectified their mistake
I know they did delete it but I don't
know how long it was up for yeah
it's that thing maybe they lift up just
do not just for enough time to get a bit
of controversy in there BAM closer to
you looks like an honest mistake just
waited until it was trending on Twitter
so our last story of the day before we
get into our fiction story a creepypasta
story Bloody Disgusting is a horror news
site and one of the writers accused dark
universe of stealing their website
design and after that a Twitter argument
ensues so what do you guys think about
this story I think it's Patti do you
think that they actually copy the design
yeah it's kind of a generic looking
designs you know it may be inspired by
it but I don't think copied it so let's
take a look at the two websites for
those of you here here so this is pretty
disgusting so we've got like the big
banner photo on the left here and then
the two smaller stories on the right and
dark universe does have that same thing
but it's not the same shape it's not the
same color mm-hmm and it just looks like
a similar layout yeah now I mean I
believe the tweets from the dark
universe guy were deleted but the Bloody
Disgusting writer his name's John Squire
says Nick to bring some calm clarity to
this your site is 100% our site the
theme layout formatting content
sentences words we're being cool about
this so just please stop you can DM me
if you want to talk further to me it
doesn't seem like it's like if they are
taking a page out of their book he
doesn't seem like a total hearing loss
right yeah I don't know I mean if if you
really want to like dig into it open up
a tab with Twitter and then open up a
tab with Facebook and tell me how
similar they look exactly you got the
news feed in the middle
you got like trending stuff on the left
and like news and things on the right
that's basically the same thing
yeah but nobody like Mark Zuckerberg
isn't like yo Twitter Dylan
you know because it's stupid to get mad
about that guy your logos blue Milo's
blue important things to worry about
guys and I don't know it just seems like
I don't read a whole lot of other news
websites but it seems like it would just
be a generic look that you would have
for a news website it just seems like
something that would come naturally
things that you know you go on Wix or
one of those websites where you have
templates just like you put it in
squares it's like here I have a
rectangle here I will have two other
rectangles and they're like hey you've
got rectangles in the same place either
you must be copy yeah it's ridiculous
I mean it just makes sense to lay it out
this way like you got the top news
stories at the top and then all the
smaller news stories down at the bottom
you know it just makes sense news sites
are gonna look like that I mean exactly
that being said they look a little bit
similar but they're still fairly
different in my mind but I do kind of
hate that just with the evolution of the
internet a lot of businesses just have
like a Facebook page or a Twitter page
and there's no way they can really
customize it so when you go to a page
like if you go to the Facebook page for
me and then if you go to mort's Facebook
page they have the same layout because
they're both Facebook pages I don't
really like that whole like what would
it be called homogenizing of the
internet yeah altum Utley we've got to
face the fact that both of the websites
haven't done anything particularly
creative they haven't done anything
that's very different now if one of them
was an outstandingly beautiful website a
designer had never been done before and
then someone blatantly copied it
you know everyone would see that but in
fact it is so generic it's a bit heavy
you copied me a well every website sort
of looks the same so yeah guys guys
you're both boring stop it I mean I mean
it's like I think that spooky guys said
people are claiming that he ripped off
mr. creepypasta
which is like the blue man habit our
that's that's silly too literally just
the color blue yeah that's like blue
that's copyright yeah that's like saying
I ripped off like nightmare Expo because
I have two letters for my Adsense and
Jesus man that was that was drama for a
bit huh Suzie I'm gonna need you not
have a cartoon face as your logo Thanks
well a lot of people actually because my
logo is partially inspired by the the
bleach holo mask so a lot of people say
like oh when you have a bleach mask as
your logo it's not like the mask is my
logo it's just like partially inspired
by it
all the time yeah of course
alright so we've got a story called
devil's road by Oh
Opie Lea I thought it was Ophelia at
first but I had to read it closer and
Mort has been nominated to read this
story because he was late meeting up
it's not okay now entertain us yeah
alright bye Opie Lea I think Harris said
I'll philia as well the thick grey
clouds look out most of the light giving
the street a dark appearance and making
my heart race it was a strange feeling
so be so afraid with no conscious reason
to be afraid up to be surveyed sorry I
walked quickly watching as the cloud
swirled and moved in odd patterns that
I've never seen before I was used to New
England winters and the cold that would
creep in unexpectedly but this was
different
the wind was fierce but not cold
the clouds were uncommon the dulled the
dulled daylight that managed to shine
into them showed swirls of colors not
normally seen I sped up positive that
something was going to happen across the
street a man took off running
his hair whooped around his head in a
frenzy and his clothing was torn and
bloodied my furrows watching him I was
in a kind of shock this wasn't normal
a moment after he ran three young men
ran after him they were laughing and
screaming calling to him I watched him I
watched him look back once and then turn
a corner
his eyes were desperate and I could feel
his fear because I was also afraid I
started walking again eyes peeled for
dangers across the street the world
seemed to have lost its mind I saw a
group of men and women chasing people I
saw people dying in horrible ways ways
that made me feel like I was going
insane a young man in a black and white
striped t-shirt was chasing until he
tripped then a group of women tore him
apart with their hands they were
literally ripping at him like zombies in
a horror movie the crazy people across
the street would stop and stare at me
but they did not cross the street their
victims would see me stop and scream
begging me to save them I was so tense
ready to run but no one came oh but no
one came towards me they would glare at
me I would shiver shake and tremble then
they would go back to whatever insanity
they had been engaging in before this is
the first time in a story that we've
gone three paragraphs would like someone
to kill Jackson or something going wrong
congratulations to opilio
should I carry on yeah my heart thumping
painfully and I began to run I had no
idea where I was going I was just
running before the madness could reach
me I stumbled against a wall and stopped
to breathe when suddenly a knife sank
into my leg at first I did not feel any
pain this shock was too great after what
seemed like hours my leg began to burn
and I squealed I looked up and across
the street was the wild looking man I
had seen being chased by a gang mr.
Davis
okay his eyes were wild and his hair red
with blood I realised abruptly that it
was not his blood that turned his
clothing red not his blood the dripped
into his eyes from his hair he lifted
how do you know that I think we'll find
out he lifted another knife and with a
flick of his wrist he threw it at me
from across the street I screamed and
fell to the ground the knife in my leg
digging deeper as I landed on it the
pain was so intense that I felt my
vision going black I yelled at myself I
couldn't pass out the man would kill me
with a shout of Glee the man raised
another knife aiming again this time I
would not be able to move away his knife
would find my flesh and there was
nothing I could do I stared at him
uncomprehendingly
the knife taking up all of my vision the
man shouted and threw the knife it's
sang as it bit through the air I closed
my eyes braced for the pain after a long
moment
I realized the pain had not come had the
man missed improve your a mr. Davis
yeah I school I squinted and what I saw
made me open them up further standing
next to me was another man he was
impeccably dressed he wore a dark suit
and shoes and his hair was black
and his skin pale it was it was me it
looks just like what twists his hand
which was decked out in ruby rings oh
maybe it wasn't me it seems like more it
may have cut out for a second there I'm
a back yet you're back okay the man
across the street looks saying for a
moment and very much afraid she is mine
the man said and while his voice was
barely more than a whisper it carried
across the wind and over the screaming
in the street the wild man heard and
dropped to the ground begging and crying
I could not understand what was going on
suddenly the wardress man threw the
knife back towards the wild man and it
landed perfectly deep in his back
the wild man screamed and the world
dressed man smiled the blade began to
glow and without cause bursts into
flames the fire spread down the man's
the fret
the fire spread down the wild man's
tattered clothing and within minutes he
was engulfed in flames that's a lot of
knife-throwing happening again I just
the world rest you know as they do oh
yeah the wardress man turned towards me
and I began to tremble in earnest his
eyes were the deepest blue and they
seemed to see into me he knelt beside me
careful not to let his knee touch the
sidewalk without a word he reached down
and
the knife from my leg and I bawled my
screaming faded into hysterical sobbing
and the man smiled pleased with the
sound of my pain he reached up his hands
inches from my face and I pulled back
but there was nowhere to go
he laughed softly and reached out I
closed my eyes tightly time passed
slowly I was afraid to open my eyes when
I finally did I realized when I finally
did open them I realized I was on the
school campus lawn a dream I began to
realize that I had fallen asleep lying
in the grass while studying
laughter bubbled hysterically I gathered
up my books together and stood quickly
but fell the pain that shot through my
leg was unprecedented Lee was
unprecedented and shocking I poured up
my jean to show a nearly healed wound in
my leg right where the blade had come me
panicked I looked around but the wind
began to whip around my face as thick
gray clouds moved in I saw a man wearing
a black and white striped t-shirt run
past me better get home big storms
coming he yelled at me as he went by
suddenly I realized that I was on the
wrong side of the street I was on the
side of the madness leaving my books I
stood and tried to hobble across the
road stopping in the middle of the road
I saw a man waiting for me a man with
deep blue eyes and a well-kept black
suit the hell did we just listen to I
like that one it's very well written I
like that like the language that was
used the descriptions in it yeah I can
kind of see why Opie Lea submitted it it
kind of reminded me of
the story that I wrote for the dream
creepypasta compilation that I did with
the dark somnium I'm just the idea of
like having this crazy dream and waking
up and realizing that there's a part of
it that's true yeah so it's sort of like
a premonition yeah and I'd be interested
to go and like analyze that further
because it seemed like there was a lot
of a lot of symbolism like the the
madness versus the reality we mean that
was a good story
yeah I agree thank you oh hey Lia Oh
Helia if she's history
yeah please opilio if you're listening
to this
shoot shoot us an email and tell us the
proper pronunciation of your name all we
want to know yeah ladies and gentlemen
it seems that our time has come but
don't worry because we've got new dead
streams on the way
[Music]
and we've lost rabbits oh sorry about
that
I lost the script all right well if you
have a story or any news about you soup
or you can send an email to Suzie's
world at gmail.com and let us know who
you would like to see as a future guest
I saw some suggestions in the chat today
so we'll definitely be reaching out to
those people more do you want to tell
them about where they can find the music
oh sure the music in the dead stream is
composed by OST maker visit is linked in
the description and go ahead and
subscribe to OST makers channel for more
great tunes and rabbit did you find the
script yet yes
do you want to go ahead yeah it's hot
you can't miss it
sorry if you missed us you can catch the
dead stream on-demand here on Susie's
world for the full experience where
you'll be able to see the real-time shet
and whatever other images we feel like
showing you you could also catch some
recent episodes on iTunes and Google
Play you can also be part of that moment
when the stream goes offline and we're
just confused and not sure if you guys
heard I'd say it's really special to be
a part of moments like those yes it is
private working the people find you on
social media
by me on Facebook and Twitter just
searching lady White Rabbit and more
half the fans connect with you they
can't find me on Instagram and on
Twitter at mortis medium and we were
happy this episode have mr. Davis join
us and mr. Davis can you tell them how
the fans can find your work you searched
me up on YouTube mr. Davis skip past the
gucci mane okay
i'm calab viously better than he is yes
you found me on twitter under the same
name
mr. Davis I think when I looked that you
were actually first yeah
Gucci Mane was second on YouTube anyway
if you search done yeah yeah that's a
whole nother story yeah anyways my name
is CeCe's world you can find me on
Facebook Google+ and Instagram is
Suzie's world my twitter handle Suzie's
world underscore [ __ ] remember
subscribe to see ZZZ world for new
Horrors every week ring that death bell
for notifications and we'll see you in
the next one assuming we've both
survived
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]